[MUSIC]
I'm Julia Brown and I'm an introvert.
I am shy.
I have nothing to say.
I'm Julia Brown [CROSSTALK].
I'm Julia [CROSSTALK].
I'm Julia Brown and
I'm an introvert.
And I love meeting new people.
But at the end of the day, I need my time
to process,
to parse out what I've learned and why
it's important.
All my life, people have pushed me to be
somebody who I'm not.
But I know that a smile from you, is all
the warmth and recognition that I need.
In order to have this discussion today,
I'd like you to remember that introversion
and extroversion are on a scale.
We are all somewhere in between.
45% of today's C suite executives, and
over half the population identify as
introverts.
But no one is 100% introverted or
extroverted.
The word introvert literally means to turn
inward and
that's exactly what introverts do.
In order to process the day's events
introverts turn to the inner world
of thought and feeling rather than living
in the moment.
Introverts focus on the meaning of events,
and how that fits into the bigger picture.
An introvert gains their energy through
reflection.
I'm Julia Brown, and I'm an introvert and
this is my story of breaking through the
noise.
Imagine, you've just walked off a plane
and into a foreign country.
It seems similar, but everything is
slightly different.
The street signs.
The smells of fried food and cigarettes.
The sounds of traffic from the main
thoroughway, or
children playing in a nearby schoolyard.
Even the way the air feels sticky on your
skin.
Being an introvert is like walking into a
foreign country everyday, where you,
where all of your senses are heightened as
you try to find your balance.
It's a rush and the feeling of
exhilaration and
adventure bubble up inside of you.
It's a puzzle that you're struggling to
figure out but
all of the pieces are constantly moving
and changing.
Over time you learn how it works, how it
fits together and what to expect.
I feel that way every time I walk into a
room full of new people or
have to deal with a new situation.
But that's also how I survived walking off
a plane into Buenos Aries,
Argentina, and apprenticing myself to a
chocolatier.
Introverts have the amazing ability to
make their friends,
acquaintances, and colleagues feel heard.
Because they are listening, really closely
to what you have to say.
They're trying to figure out what makes
you you.
And why you do the things that you do.
There's a reason, nerdy awkward Mark
Zuckerberg invented the social network.
It's because he knew what you were going
to do before you did it yourself.
I had studied Spanish in college.
But nothing had prepared me for
the rapid fire Spanish needed to work in
an Argentine kitchen.
Being an introvert surprisingly worked in
my favor.
By, by closely watching and working with
the people around me,
I was able to learn much more quickly how
things should be done.
How not to burn the chocolate, how long to
let the Ganache set for, and the delicate
flick of the wrist needed to make a design
just so on the top of a truffle.
Even in a fast-paced, loud kitchen, where
pans are clattering,
the radio is blaring Mana, and people are
shouting from one end of the kitchen to
the other, you as an introvert can connect
with people on a deep and
personal level and break through the
noise.
After I was a chocolatier I became a hedge
fund analyst.
>> [LAUGH]
>> It's a little bit of a career non
sequitur, I know, but it's almost the
perfect job for an introvert.
You spend all day reading the news,
industry reports,
interviewing experts and mom and pop
business owners.
And then at the end of the day, you step
back and
you distill that information into
investable ideas.
But the world of investing is a world of
noise.
The phones are constantly ringing.
CNBC is blasting behind you and
you feel as though you're living in a
perpetual earthquake
where the next piece of news could shatter
the foundations of your investment thesis.
Your ideas.
The only way to survive in this world is
to have conviction.
A belief so strong, it's interwoven with
your personality.
Introverts are naturally analytical, by
taking the time to watch,
listen, and process events.
They can have contrarian unconventionals
or unconventional or
even ahead of the curve ideas.
But these same analytical tendencies
force you to recognize just how fragile
your ideas are.
You spend so much time thinking about your
ideas that their flaws and
cracks are obvious to you and erode your
conviction.
As an introvert you have to fight this
tendency to turn inward.
To write off your ideas because of their
imperfections.
As an introvert, you have to make yourself
vulnerable.
These ideas, that ones that are integral
to who we are,
are the ones we need to share with the
world.
The returns are worth the risks.
Warren Buffett was a 25 year old no name
kid who couldn't get a job.
So he started his own investment firm.
He bought companies where nobody else saw
value.
Today, he's the greatest investor of our
time.
Mr. Buffett is a self-described introvert.
I started working at a hedge fund as a 25
year old no name kid
as a part time office manager.
Within three years I was a full time
analyst and
two of the ideas I had worked on were our
two biggest returns in the fund.
I'm not saying I'm the next Warren Buffet
but I do know that
having conviction means knowing where the
limits of your belief system are.
I know which events can render my ideas
useless and
I can quantify that downside for you.
But by knowing how large that downside is
I also know by how much the returns
outweigh that risk.
Having conviction means knowing that you
might fail but
how much better it will be if you succeed.
Know your ideas, be unconventional, break
through the noise.
At this point, you're probably saying to
yourself, I've heard all of this before.
I know it, but how do I actually get
anyone to notice?
How do I speak up?
It is impossible to break through the
noise without speaking up.
Believe me, I've tried every way.
And it's something I still struggle with
today.
Which is why I am here on a stage in a
room full of people.
Every day I struggle to break through the
noise of my own self doubt.
Luckily, I've had my own champions, my
family, friends, and
mentors, who were able to break through my
quiet and
protected facade, and find something that
they too believed in.
These people have paved the way for me to
make some seemingly crazy choices that
turned out to be the best decisions of my
life.
These people pull me out of my own
protective cone of silence and
give me the strength to keep trying when
everything seems impossible.
Find your champions.
They will give you the power to break
through the noise.
In a world that is constantly asking you
to speak up, to make yourself vulnerable,
to make yourself heard, sometimes breaking
through the noise seems hard.
But it is the perfect opportunity to rise
to the occasion and challenge yourself.
Taking this risk becomes so much easier if
you value yourself.
Know your skills.
You have the incredible ability to make
people feel heard
in a world where that's all anyone around
you is asking for.
And do you have the ability to come up
with creative,
outside of the box ideas that can shatter
the limits of the world that we live in?
Know yourself.
Challenge yourself.
Trust yourself.
Break through the noise.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]